tout à l'heure en fait je me balader
tranquillement dans la rue et j'ai eu
l'impression que mon téléphone avaient
vibré dans ma poche je les sorties en
fait y avait rien ça vous est déjà
arrivé ou pas oui lever la main si ça
vous est arrivé
ok est ce que vous réalisez quand même
que ce que je viens de décrire ici c'est
ce qu'on appelle une hallucination
c'est quand même dingue de se dire que
on est tellement conditionnés par la
technologie aujourd'hui qu'on en est
arrivé à s'imaginer des choses qui
n'existent pas sauf que problème d'avoir
une addiction c'est que c'est aussi un
manque de choix c'est qu'on se sent
obligé de faire quelque chose c'est une
certaine forme de liberté qu'on nous a
ôté et quand on regarde ce qui est en
train de se passer dans le futur ça fait
très peur la trajectoire du nombre
d'objets connectés qu'il va exister est
exponentielle en 1990 il n'y avait pas
d'objets connectés
c'était ce qu'on appelait le hunt club
le monde était analogique très réel très
concret en 1995 c'est l'époque
d'internet avec le premier objet
connecter l'ordinateur connecté à
internet est la première forme
d'intrusion avec les emails
dix ans plus tard c'est l'ère du mobile
donc internet est mort désolé c'est
l'ère du mobile et ces trois objets que
nous avons chacun un ordinateur un
smartphone et une tablette
sauf qu'en fait ces objets au lieu de se
synchroniser entre eux sont réellement
trois objets indépendant ce qui fait que
la perception qu'on a de la technologie
dans notre vie de tous les jours et
trois fois plus intrusive
si quelqu'un aujourd'hui m'envoie un
message ça va sonner sur mon ordinateur
sur mon smartphone sur ma tablette et
même d'ailleurs sûrement watch ça me
pose un petit problème parce que dans
dix ans avec l'internet des objets donc
cette nouvelle ère du numérique
ce sera 100 milliards d'objets connectés
sur terre 100 milliards d'objets
connectés c'est 15 par personne mais
prenant en compte que dans les pays
développés on a beaucoup plus de
consommation de ce type de choses ça
sera peut-être une centaine par personne
et
cette trajectoire ne fait qu'augmenter
alors juste pour une seconde
imaginez vous arrivez dans une pièce où
chaque ampoule chaque chaise chaque
table chaque porte est connectée est en
train finalement d'être en compétition
pour votre attention en train de vous
demander est ce que vous voulez vraiment
allumé la lumière mais au niveau de
chaque ampoule
vous êtes sûr que c'est bien que vous
asseoir et sinon c'est peut-être pas une
bonne idée en fait c'est absolument
terrible et si avec déjà aujourd'hui
trois objets on a déjà des addictions
des hallucinations
ça veut dire qu'avec 100 objets chacun
dans notre quotidien on va finalement
devenir des esclaves de la technologie
la technologie nous dictera comment on
doit se comporter et cette façon de se
comporter aura été inventé par quelques
méga corporation qui ont créé ces objets
en premier lieu alors je ne sais pas
pour vous mais moi je dis non à ce monde
là ça vous intéresse vous dis dans ce
monde là bas alors bien sûr que non
heureusement on a une solution c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle et je parle pas ici des
robots qui vont tous nous tuer machin je
parle en fait d'une forme d'intelligence
artificielle qu'on appelle
l'intelligence contextuel
c'est l'idée qu'en analysant
l'environnement autour d'un utilisateur
on peut comprendre ce qu'il est en train
de faire et donc anticiper ses
intentions automatisant la majorité des
interactions nous avons avec la
technologie
sauf que l'intelligence artificielle
mais un petit peu plus de temps à
démarrer et dernièrement elle a commencé
à prendre d'un coup la vitesse ce qui
veut dire que dans un futur pas trop
lointain
allez on va dire 2025 les capacités de
ces intelligences artificielles
contextuel seront nettement supérieurs à
la friction qu'engendre la technologie
et il s'agit bien là en fait de la
révolution numérique dont tout le monde
parle
l'internet des objets ça sera fini un
jour aussi c'est ce qu'on appelle le
ubiquitous computing l'informatique
ubiquitaire c'est l'idée que les objets
seront tellement intelligent et intégrée
dans nos vies qu'on ne s'apercevra même
plus qu'il existe la friction de la
technologie un autre quotidien aura
totalement disparu
on aura la sensation de vivre dans un
monde totalement déconnecté tout en
gardant tous les bénéfices de la
technologie
alors moi je trouve ça formidable
franchement je trouve ça absolument
incroyable et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je fais ça au jour le jour
sauf que le problème c'est que c'est
dans dix ans donc en attendant il va
bien falloir faire quelque chose pour
essayer d'amoindrir tous ces objets qui
sont envahissants alors laissez moi vous
expliquer comment en analysant des
données de ma propre vie
je suis capable aujourd'hui déjà de
créer des objets qui sont en mesure
d'anticiper quasiment tout ce que je
compte faire si on prend les emails les
emails c'est super intéressant et qu'on
regarde les destinataires de chacun des
messages que j'ai envoyée
c'est ce qu'on appelle le graphe social
c'est-à-dire la connectivité entre les
différentes personnes avec qui j'ai
interagit dans ma vie et tous ces
groupes de personnes sont des personnes
qui étaient souvent dans les mêmes
messages
et quand on prend la bulle la taille de
la bulle comme étant proportionnel au
nombre de message que j'envoie à
quelqu'un on voit très rapidement les
gens à qui j'ai de plus en plus
d'interactions donc au milieu les normes
bulls est un des cofondateurs on
s'envoie beaucoup trop d'e-mails mais
bon voilà c'est comme ça et tout autour
de lui à tous les gens de mon équipe
c'est très intéressant pourquoi parce
que hormis la capacité de qualifier le
type de relation que j'ai avec quelqu'un
on peut aussi commencer à analyser le
contenu donc on peut voir que c'est
quelqu'un avec qui j'ai une relation
professionnelle ou plutôt personnelle et
ça c'est très important quand on veut
par exemple faire du traitement du
langage naturel des si je suis en train
d'envoyer un texto à 1 mais cofondateur
moi je sais exactement de quoi je parle
je sais que en train de parler de dîner
ce soir pour sortir pour s'amuser mais
l'ordinateur lui l'en n'a aucune idée
parce que s'ils ne regarde que le texto
ce qu'ils voient c'est une discussion un
petit peu aléatoires avec un gars mais
si jamais il sait que cette personne là
ces bocaux fondateur avec qui je suis à
la fois amis et avec qui je travaille
du coup il peut dire tiens ça c'est
peut-être un rendez vous social et long
qui peut analyser ça est ce dire moi je
vais garder l'adresse de ce restaurant
peut-être qu'on en aura besoin plus tard
et si on prend cette information et
qu'on la croise avec quelque chose comme
le calendrier où j'aurai juste marquer
dîner avec michael les ordinateurs
maintenant est capable de comprendre
qu'il s'agit d'un dîner avec michael
moore cofondateur avec qui j'étais en
train de discuter dans ce texto d'aller
dans ce restaurant là et ça c'est
important parce que ça permet
typiquement à mon ordinateur ou à mon
téléphone de s'assurer qu'on aille table
dans le restaurant où on va ou bien de
me commander un taxi à l'avancé des
interactions en moins finalement qu'on
enlève qui relève de la friction
sauf qu'évidemment pas tout ce que je
fais dans mon calendrier heureusement
parfois je fais des choses un petit peu
par habitude aussi et pour finalement
mesurer et comprendre les habitudes des
gens on a une autre source de données
qui est extrêmement
leckie et la géolocalisation si on
regarde par exemple tout au long d'une
journée
la géolocalisation de mon smartphone on
peut voir les endroits où je me suis
déplacé si on est ensuite capable de
comprendre que cet endroit
spécifiquement c'était un restaurant ou
une salle de sport ou alors que c'est un
bureau eh bien on peut voir ce que j ai
fait donc on en fait une activité qui
est très dépendante du lieu objet terre
si on prend ensuite ses trajectoires ces
séquences de lieux que j'ai visités
d'activité sur plusieurs journées est
bien là maintenant on à mes habitudes
on comprend que j'aime aller au bureau
le matin en métro on comprend que je
vais en général des jeunes et en
marchant pas très loin du bureau
on comprend que je vais aux sports le
mercredi et le vendredi
à la fin de mes rendez vous j'ai dans
mon calendrier on comprend que le
vendredi soir j'aime à la république
prendre un verre avec mes amis on peut
d'ailleurs croisé ça avec mes textos
pour comprendre aussi avec qui est ce
que j'ai envie d'y aller et quand on
prend ce type d'informations là au
niveau individuel et qu'on la grève au
niveau d'une population entière
bah là on peut mesurer des flux de
population on peut par exemple mesuré
combien de personnes sont dans les
transports publics
combien de personnes il ya sur la route
combien de personnes fréquentent des
magasins et ça c'est très important
parce que quand on parle finalement de
ville intelligente il faut être capable
de mesurer sa pour préempter et crée des
infrastructures adaptive finalement ce
qu'un ordinateur a besoin pour prédire
ce que je veux faire de ma vie est ce
que j'ai besoin c'est une séquence
d'activité très contextualisés donc il a
besoin de mettre en commun ses couches
sociales
ces couches environnemental ces couches
personnel pour finalement se dire tiens
là maintenant moi riend ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est ça et la manière
dont j'ai envie de me comporter que mes
objets et c'est ça alors c'est cool ça
fait peur c'est un peu des deux
c'est à dire que d'un côté on se dit bon
bah tous ces objets connectés on veut
devenir des esclaves de la technologie
donc il faut donner de la data parce que
bon soyons clair le but de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est de
comprendre qu' on est donc il faut bien
qu'à un moment leur donne accès à la
donner mais de l'autre côté de
centraliser toute cette donne et quelque
part ça fait quand même assez peur c'est
à dire qu'il ya une entreprise ou un
gouvernement ou autre qui va pour axe
avoir accès à toute ma vie et qui
potentiellement pourrait en abuser alors
est ce que c'est possible de proposer
des services aussi intelligent sans
jamais avoir accès à cette donnée
personnelle en premier lieu tout le
monde va vous dire non moi je dis ce
sont des menteurs
en fait aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
qui s'appelle le privacy by design
l'idée du privacy by design c'est
concret des services en intégrant des
garde fous de protection de vie privée
dans la conception même des produits et
des algorithmes qui en ont besoin pour
cela en fait on a deux types de
technologies clés la première c'est
l'intelligence artificielle embarquée
c'est à dire finalement plutôt que de
prendre de la donner sur un smartphone
et de l'envoyer dans le cloud eu là où
elle devient accessible
on va la laisser sur le smartphone elle
ne sort pas et les algorithmes de
traitement sont locales dans téléphone
donc c'est ce qu'on fait si on veut
analyser les e-mails les choses comme ça
sauf qu'évidemment pas tout peut se
faire sur le téléphone si on en vit
proposer des services qui nécessitent
plusieurs objets ou plusieurs personnes
ben là il ya un moment on doit faire
transiter de la data pour ça il ya une
deuxième technologies clés qui commence
à se développer qu'on appelle la crypte
sion au beau mot refik alors je sais
c'est à dire d'un peu d'un gros mot mais
l'idée c'est simple c'est que on en
crypte la donner sur l'objet mais ça
conserve certaines propriétés
mathématiques comme les additions les
multiplications est donc en fait seul
l'utilisateur à la clé décryptage ils
envoient leurs données en crypté sur un
serveur qui fait ses petits calculs qui
moulinent un résultat qui en crypté qui
renvoie à l'utilisateur que celui peut
décrypter
on est capable par exemple aujourd'hui
de dire si deux personnes sont au même
endroit sans jamais partagé leur
géolocalisation
c'est quand même incroyable et donc
quand on prend ces deux technologies ce
qu'on réalise c'est qu'on peut
reproduire tous les services qui
existent aujourd'hui
sans jamais prendre de risques sur notre
vie privée donc le monde du futur cette
révolution numérique ce n'est pas qu'ils
révolution d'intelligence c'est aussi
une révolution dans la manière dont on
gère ses données personnelles et les
deux concepts sont absolument
indissociables et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui va différencier le monde tel qu'on
nous l'a toujours dcri c'est-à-dire un
petit peu comme une scène du cinquième
élément un monde futuriste qui est
extrêmement oppressant où tous les
immeubles sont faits une métal avec des
néons et la technologie qui est
omniprésente en train nous dicter et de
nous dire quoi faire un monde qui est
fliqué en permanence avec de la
publicité envahissante
ultra personnalisé qui va nous obliger
absolument acheter ce truc là ce monde
là il n'a pas besoin d'exister
aujourd'hui le monde tel que je
l'imaginé tels que j'aimerais qu'on
puisse le vivre plus tard finalement
ressemble plutôt à ça c'est un monde où
où la technologie est devenue tellement
intelligente tellement intégrée dans nos
vies où elle a littéralement disparu
c'est à dire qu'elle est partie en
arrière-plan elle nous a donné la
sensation d'être déconnecté en
permanence comme quand on est à la plage
tout en gardant les bénéfices qu'elle
puisse apporter et ce monde c'est
important
c'est important car finalement plutôt
que de devenir addict à la technologie
on pourra être maître de ses propres
choix et être maître de ses propres
choix d'une certaine façon ça veut aussi
dire être libre d'être qui on veut merci